hey Leute ich zeige euch heute einen Tag
in meinem Leben als Youtuber Marketing
Mensch und Retouren Händler viel Spaß um
9:15 Uhr klingelt mein Wecker und ich
weiß das ist relativ spät aber vorher
kann man mit mir eh nichts anfangen mit
einem kleinen Espresso und einem kleinen
Frühstück geht's in den Tag ich schaue
mir dabei mal irgendeinen Scheiß auf
Youtube an und dann geht's auch schon ab
ins Büro schauen wir uns mal das Wetter
an ja bisschen regnerisch na ja so ist
das an dem Montag ja Wagen gestartet und
Abfahrt zum Büro schauen wir mal wie ist
da die Lage alles wie immer ich bin da
der einzige ein bisschen einsam manchmal
aber naja kann man nichts machen dann
hatten wir unser erstes Wochen Meeting
wie gesagt war eine Montag war ein
bisschen traurig weil die Person die
hier sind verlässt uns und sie war schon
so lange dabei mach's gut bei Lana dann
habe ich mich an ein paar Grafiken
gesetzt ich arbeite nämlich gerade mit
einem Künstler der kommt bald raus das
ist ein brataner total revolutioniert
checkt das gerne mal aus und ja dann
ging es zu Mama erstmal ein bisschen
Mittag